-We're joined now
by one of my dearest friends
And you can hear him right now
on the new
"Oh, Hello: The P'dcast."
Please welcome back to the sho
John Mulaney, everybody.
-Do I sit into it?
-Yeah, you can sit in.
Do you want to walk into i
like you're -- Yeah.
-Okay.
-We'll have Fred add some musi
in post.
-Am I waiting for my name?
-John Mulaney!
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Hi!
-Oh, my dog barking.
How are you, Seth?
-I'm very happy
to have you here.
You are, as you know,
you are the record holder
for most frequent guest
on the show.
-Oh, I still have it?
-You still have it.
Martha Stewart very close.
[ Clears throat ]
Excuse me, she was just on
And I feel as though it's good
to always, like,
keep the same buffer
between you and her.
-Which is I always have
one over Martha Stewart.
-Yeah.
I think that's just for safety
-Right. Right.
Okay, I mean,
I'm always a little nervou
with her hellhound
on my trail like that.
-Yeah, exactly.
I like asking people
how they're spending their tim
during quarantine.
I sort of picked up
from social media
that you're watching
old television shows.
-Yeah, I'm --
well, I'm catching up on
"Real Housewives of New York."
I'm starting from season 1
which took place in 2008.
And I'm currently in season 3,
which is I believe
we're in late 2009.
-Gotcha.
-You know me. I'm an
Orange County Beverly Hills guy.
-What was the impetus of
going back and watching that
You've never seen it?
-I'd never seen
"Real Housewives of New York."
I was very aware of it.
And then my wife, Anna, said
"That's leaps and bounds beyon
'Beverly Hills'
and 'Orange County.'"
And I had never seen
a lick of it.
She said,
"Let's start at season 1."
And we did, and it's fantastic
-You do like it?
So it's living up to
her highest standards?
-Yeah, I like it
very, very much.
Yeah, her endorsement
was exactly right.
Have you ever seen it?
-I haven't.
I remember it would sort of be
on, you know, at "SNL"
in the corner sometimes,
and I never really watched it.
-Do you know Bethenny Frankel?
-I've met Bethenny Frankel
a few times, yeah.
-A few times. Okay.
Because I remember you had
a bottle of her vodka
in your office.
-I feel like it was
maybe tequila, though.
But I can't remember.
-Her name is also on a tequila
-Yeah.
-Fantastic.
-Like, a skinny 'tini.
Maybe I'm getting this
all mixed up.
-All those words,
"skinny 'tini," sound right.
-Based on watching
"Real Housewives,"
that led you to take the
Myers-Briggs personality test?
-It didn't lead me to take it,
but I did begin thinking
where I'd fit in among
the housewives, you know.
And I do that with most seasons,
be it "Orange County,"
"Beverly Hills" or now "RHONY,
which is
"Real Housewives of New York."
I try to figure out who I woul
be in the show
and how I would deal with
a different conflict.
You know one thing
they never, ever do ever
on that show is apologize.
-Oh, wow.
-So let's say that I said
that you were tacky, Seth,
and that -- and that you -
you were tacky
and you show up to events
like a stalker.
I made that up but that coul
easily be on the show, right
I tell Fred this.
Fred tells you immediately
-Right.
-We're at a function
within hours together.
And you call me out on it
and you're mad at me.
-Sure.
-The way I would
apologize is say,
"I want to just put this
behind us."
[ Laughter ]
And you'd hug me
and you'd go,
"Okay. I just want to put --
I said, "We're good, right
"We're good."
And never would I say that I
insulted you directly on camer
knowing it would get back to you
with little remorse.
I would just say,
"We're good, right?
I want to put this behind us."
-You've also noticed
that it does seem as thoug
the characters on those show
are hyperaware
that they are on reality shows
-Yeah, especially
in the beginning of
"Real Housewives of New York,"
because it's like a --
it's not a new concept,
a reality show.
It's been around
for about eight years
by the time "RHONY" starts
It's easier to say "RHONY.
So --
-[ Laughs ]
-But they still talk about it.
If you watch "RHOBH,"
which is "Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills."
"RHOBH."
If you watch "RHOBH,"
that island that people go to,
they don't talk anymore abou
how they're on a reality show.
But in "Real Housewives of
New York" circa 2009,
someone will say something like,
"Well, I don't want to share
that. That's personal."
And the rest of them go,
"We're on a reality show.
You have to tell us."
And they'll be, like,
arguing with each other
and be like,
"Well, why would you do that?"
They say like,
"'Cause it's a reality show.
And so they're very aware
when they're at an event
that they are
marketing themselves.
So, someone might say,
"Why is there a skinnygirl
margarita sign up?"
And she says,
"Because it's a reality show
and I'm marketing myself."
Very self-aware and on the nose.
-Are there parts -- does it show
you a part of New York
that you're nostalgic for,
especially during this tim
where we're stuck inside?
-Every part of outdoor New Yor
I'm nostalgic for,
but this drives home
how nostalgic I am
for any part of New York
because they'll show, like
1st and 70th.
I'm like, "Oh. That's only -
That's only eight blocks fro
the United Nations.
An area I hate.
Oh, York and 80th?
Oh, I could walk there
against the wind."
-[ Laughs ]